(acclamations)
- Gabriel Boric, jeune
ex-leader étudiant de 36 ans,
succède à Sebastian Pinera,
dans le palais de la Moneda,
(déclics d'appareils photo)
Il aura la tâche difficile
de répondre aux revendications
(tir)
qui ont été le cauchemar
du président sortant
de Santiago et partout au pays.
ANTOINE MAILLET, prof. sciences
pol., Université du Chili
autour de cette prise
dedede pouvoir. C'est quand même
un président qui suscite
caractéristiques personnelles.Oe
un renouveau dans les formes
de par sa jeunesse, de par
sa provenance des mobilisations
sociales.chchchchchchchchchchchs
vovovovoir et le choix du
cabinet du nouveau présidentquqe
dedededes voies nouvelles.
Sur les 24 ministres,1414141414t
à la Défense, une petite-filled,
renversé pdidididictateur
Augusto Pinochet.
la maison de Salvador Allende
que s'est tenue la première
réunion du cabinet,
dit qu'elle a toujours aimé
le mot "socialisme".
(en espagnol) d d d d d d d d de
et les milieux des affaires
en nommant aux Finances
le président de la banque
- Il y a des attentes
très fortes : un retour de plus
d'égalité, d'un meilleur accèsc,
de meilleures recettes.
Beaucoup de thèmes qui
sont très importants pour
leur vie quotidienne et
où la patience a certaines
limites aussi. Donc, il y a
et une pression importante.
- Le nouveau président se dit
convaincu de pouvoir répondre
que demande la majorité
des Chiliens.
- Ces changements dépendront
de la n,n,n,n,n,n, attendue
en juin, d'une nouvelle
constitution par la Conventie,es
le président Pinera pour calmer
la révolte populaire.
(applaudissements)
Constituante et le référendum
qui va suivre vont être
décisifs. C'est vrai queBoBoBoBc
ne dépend pas uniquement de ça,
mais sera forcément jugé
en partie par rapport à ça.toto,
un vote qu'il faudra gagner
pour ceux qui veulent
une nouvelle constitution.
automatique.
- Cette nouvelle constitution
devrait remplacer celle héritée
qui a accru les inégalités
qui minent la ieieieieieieiens